that love is still there 100
um i love
i love my sister jamie lynn spears gets
emotional talking about her sister
britney spears
i am now ready to tell the story on
wednesday the 30 year old entertainer
sat down with good morning america's
juju chang and spoke out about her
famous sister whose 13-year
conservatorship came to an end in
november
i've only ever loved and supported her
and done what's right by her and she
knows that so i don't know why we're in
this position right now jamie lynn went
on to say she's happy that britt's
conservatorship was dissolved late last
year adding that she didn't understand
the extent of the conservatorship when
it first started and she still doesn't
fully understand it now
when it was put into place i was 17 year
old i was about to have a baby so i
didn't understand what was happening nor
was i focused on that i was focused on
the fact that i was a 17 year old about
to have a baby i understand just as
little about it then as i do now the mom
of two who has often been criticized by
britney's fans for allegedly not doing
more to help her sister while she was in
the conservatorship said for the first
time that she in fact did work to
provide her sister with resources to
potentially end it
i've always been my sister's biggest
supporter so when she needed help i set
up ways to do so
went out of my way to make sure that
she had the contacts she needed to
possibly go ahead and
in this conservatorship and just end
this all for our family if it's going to
cause this much discord why continue it
but jamie lynn said all that didn't go
so well for her i even spoke to her
legal team who
i
her legal team previous legal team and
that did not end well in my favor so i
did take the steps to help
but how many times can i take the steps
without
you know she has to walk through the
door
back in june before the ruling came down
to end britney's conservatorship the
lucky singer appeared remotely before a
judge to address the court directly with
an explosive testimony slamming her
family i think it's a very big deal that
she's speaking out and she has told the
court she wants her voice heard and she
thinks this is the best way to get her
point across
well after britt's testimony jamie lynn
insisted she had her sister's back
posting this emotional clip to instagram
my sister knows i love and support her
that's the only person i owe anything to
i'm not my family i'm my own person i'm
speaking for myself
i'm so proud of her
for using her voice
i'm so proud of her for requesting new
counsel like i told her to do many years
ago the former zoe 101 star also shut
down the haters who slammed her for not
speaking out publicly sooner maybe i
didn't support her the way the public
would like me to
with a hashtag on a public platform but
i can assure you that i've supported my
sister long before there was a hashtag
and i'll support her long after the
following month brittany criticized her
sister on instagram pointing to jamie
lynn's tribute performance when the pop
star was honored with the icon award at
the 2017 radio disney music awards quote
i don't like that my sister showed up at
an awards show and performed my songs to
remixes my so-called support system hurt
me deeply this conservatorship killed my
dreams so all i have is hope and hope is
the only thing in this world that is
very hard to kill yet people still try
well jamie lynn addressed all that in
her chat with good morning america too
honestly it was
somewhat confusing to me about that and
i actually have spoke to her about that
i have
cleared up with the fact that i don't
think she's personally upset with me
about that truthfully i don't know why
that bothers her i was doing a tribute
to honor my sister and all the
amazing things that she's done
following britt's public criticism of
jamie lynn the mental health charity
this is my brave publicly declined to
the former nickelodeon star's offer in
october to donate proceeds from the
sales of her upcoming memoir things i
should have said to them a source at the
time told et that jamie lynn was quote
extremely upset by the situation
jamie lynn has been forced to stay
silent for years and now she's being
attacked for finally speaking her truth
people fail to realize that jamie lynn
has suffered some of the same trauma
that britney has this isn't brittany or
jamie lynn this is about a family trauma
and how it affects each person
differently there is a bigger
conversation to be had about supporting
every voice
as for her older sister's current mental
state jamie lynn isn't willing to
comment
i can't really speak to anyone else's
state of mind i don't think that's fair
but i'm allowed to say how i felt in
those
because that matters
it matters that i was in pain
you